hi I was asked by a student the other
week where's the best place to go in my
opinion in the world to if I want if
they wanted to train as
Uchi a living
student uh and I sort of said I don't
know it's uh many a lot of the places
that uh did do it I've stopped doing it
and um could go to Japan there's several
dojos there if it's a what we call iwama
sty like
Ito then to go to the enses dojo in
iwama where there's a mixture of
teachers there some teachers are from
the
aai hu Style aido with a mixture and um
other teachers who have lived in all
their life and they teach what would be
the same as what cyto Sensi taught them
and uh there may be what oeni also
taught them because he started when they
were
teenagers but it made me start thinking
about
um what people want for Mido in this day
and age you know here we are in 2024
2025 coming up and um the numbers are
been quite
stagnant uh and if anything dropping in
the last 20 years so it's hard to keep a
dojo going when the numbers are down to
six people on a regular training
night they might have 20 names on their
books but with all the uh pressures of
living
nowadays I'm forever seeing on WhatsApp
uh in our local Club um Works got them
held up or sorry they're just busy uh
not feeling so well um other
commitments this list of
items have been there ever since I can
remember but going I want to really just
talk today about uh what I think
an
ioka should try and put on their list of
thoughts I've often said in my films
that we're made of muscle flesh bone
ligaments tendons
fascia
this
torso the legs
arms it it needs working it doesn't
matter whether you you know you're held
up at work
or your lifestyle is hectic you do need
to look after your body if you want to
get to a good old
age and um keep physically
fit by spending more and more hours at
work will not do
this so let's get down to the how do you
become a better
iido there's the technique
that if I criticize your style iido it's
very technical we look at very fine
detail there's not so much fun in it as
I believe many other styles of iido but
then they're not as accurate in my
opinion um for
self-defense where if you train your War
iido correctly it's much more detailed
correct postures uh minimal movement but
uh what you do is about applying the
technique that will work in a real
situation if
required but the person that's busy at
work and has a hectic lifestyle but
they've got the bug and the bug of iido
gets deeper in them and they want more
from it then the question that the
somebody asked me
is where would they find
this well you can find it in your own
Dojo but you would have to
train almost every day of the
week if you can't train every day of the
week in the dojo because the dojo is not
open then three times a week is minimum
really you need to train perhaps you
could visit other clubs they may have a
different style but at least you're
getting this body the physical body
exercised the to me unless you really
train hard in aama style iido you won't
get the aerobic workout that you need
where a lot of the other styles you will
you'll get the aerobic exercise but you
won't get the
Marshal where um
it it does work in a real situation this
is why the uh iido has got such a bad
name because it doesn't um tend to lend
itself to looking real or being real to
most martial
artists who do what I call hardcore uh
fighting
styles the biggest thing is you should
enjoy doing
it and and it should give you a buzz if
you're a perfectionist and you like
detail and you like scrutinizing things
in fine detail then your armor sty like
you know I would say the one for you if
you just want an aerobic workout a
friendly atmosphere
people um you know always smiling and
and more like a a big family attitude
then choose one of the other stars
it doesn't matter whether you're a q
grade or a
downgrade what do you'll find is how do
you get better well you have to think a
lot you have to think a lot off the mat
uh there's training time on the mat but
I'm purposely sitting here talking to
you now and my shoulders are up I know
my shoulders are up because I'm
concentrating on talking to you now the
thing with aikidoka that train regular
every day of the week and I've got some
students in Russia who do actually train
every day of the
week and they learn how to hold their
body mass in a much lower position than
people who only train once or twice a
week even three times a week your body
mass will be higher in your
body if you stand on weing scows yes the
weing scows will tell you what you weigh
but that's not the mess I'm talking
about so what I'm going to do is I'm
just going to drop my shoulders you
might have seen them drop I'll pick them
up and exaggerate you might find oh and
and most people know that in life you'll
find yourself in this tense position and
you're oh dear I didn't realize I was
tense you might think to
yourself well that means that your body
mass is up here so you wouldn't be
grounded and when attacking on the in
the dojo when attacking nag or gripping
nag then your body mass will be not as
condensed as somebody who trains a
lot you can you can enhance this by as
soon as you get the mat laid down in the
dojo try to do nonstop
backwards and forwards 25
ukis left and right when you you know
left and right backwards and forwards
backwards and forwards try to do 25
without
stopping because what you'll do is
you'll find that the brain has to
quickly switch into looking after your
self mode because you might have just
come off the street your body may be in
a vulnerable state and you don't want to
damage
yourself and if I was to tell you from a
wellbeing point of view I'd say stretch
your body slowly warm your body up
slowly
but I'm really just telling you how you
learn how to quickly think about
creating mass and that is if you do 25
hamis backwards and forwards forward
hamis backwards and
forwards once you get stop being dizzy
and you get used to that then you
increase it in multiple of 10 you can do
backwood emis if you wish the same way
do backwood emis
um 25 is quite a task for just
backwards but the more you do your ukam
is the more you'll smooth out your body
the more your mind will be looking after
your body and slowly slowly you will
learn how to relax quicker so instead of
your shoulders being here you're being a
relaxed mode this will create Mass
that's
controllable you won't have to think
about it you just automatically like
sediment in a wine bottle it'll go down
and my students in Russia I always knew
when I used to leave the UK and go to
Russia and I call up uh the regular
trainees that are very dedicated and
they either run a dojo or they train
every day at the dojo when they grip my
when they grip my wrist I knew straight
away the depth of their
mass and that would tell me how
dedicated a student they were they can't
feel it themselves the same as you can't
feel the weight you are until you step
on the way sculls I'm overweight right
now because I'm on um a course of
steroids you know bigger chin fatter
belly um all the things that we
criticize oursel for but when you're ill
you have to look after
yourself and um till you get better but
the mind can still work so if you can't
physically do iido then you can still
think about
it
so if you most people can do the ukis
even if you are asked um the teacher if
they could set time aside if if it's
really tie your time within a sports
hall or something perhaps you can ask
your teacher if you could have time to
do chemist others may want to join in
but it should be a personal thing for
you not as a teaching Aid so if you're a
teacher you shouldn't be teaching it
because even if you're teaching it you
might do you might show them 25 who can
is just to show them that you can do
them but your thinking and trying to be
precise means that your mass will not
lower itself it will it will stay high
because you're mentally trying to get
every single who can be correct for
those watching
you so once you've got mass in your body
your strikes become more powerful your
grip becomes greater
but then when you're Naga and you're
doing the
technique the sheer naggie they're going
through moving their arm the mass will
move it and you will think that they're
not resisting you as much and this is
how you get feedback thinking oh they
don't seem to be so difficult as they
used to be so your mass is working then
better for
you so it it just a quick uh
film to say if you want to create mass
and not walk around shoulders up or even
tense hands if you're sitting in a chair
you might find what that you're tensing
your hands for no reason until that
reason you've noticed
it do
chemist
25 when you stop getting dizzy and it's
becoming easier add 10
ukis the same with backward ukis but my
recommendation would be start off with
10 backwards and forwards left and right
side without stopping without going you
know without getting to the other side
of the mat slowly turning round going
back you turn round as if you make that
part of a new Cami so you quickly go get
the moment you get to the other side as
a as a comp competition Olympic swimmer
how they touch the end of the pool and
quickly spring back into swimming again
that's how you want your ukis to be
there doesn't want to be a pause that
breaks the ukami up it wants to be a
continuous
flow okay please contact me if you need
more information but but I'd like to
make some short videos on how to become
better iido and what you have to do is
you have to hone the body and make the
body more efficient before you can have
easier
techniques thank you for your time thank
you for listening and um I hope you find
it this enjoyable and of Greater
knowledge than you had before